Vale, se utiliza para controlar los
saltos de red que deben seguir los
paquetes hasta alcanzar su destino y
además eh proporciona información sobre
otros parámetros de internet. Cuando el
números altos es uno, esto quiere decir
que la red es plana, es decir, se trata
de una red de local.
Vale, esto lo podíamos comprobar. Tú
estás conectado, Álvaro, a la
estás conectado aquí al a Atame.
Sí,
pues eso lo podíamos mirar.
Espera
que me saque la
el documento este, pero
Este
Vale, este este no es porque este es
este es a ver a ver si es este.
Est me que sí.
E va,
un segundo, eh, que que estoy buscando
la cosa.
Vale, pues posiblemente
vamos a ver a ver si es este. Yo creo
que es este de aquí.
A ver,
vale, sí, sí que es este.
Vale, estamos estábamos hablando del del
tráer.
¿Sabes tu IP? Este árbo,
¿eh? Mira,
a ver si nos si nos deja, si no lo
haremos con
con
lo podíamos hacer con máquinas
virtuales, o sea, o o lo podemos hacer
con Packet Tráer, pero vamos a hacerlo
aquí a ver si nos deja.
Yo tengo la 60, si quieres,
¿sabes dónde te aparece? Eh, pero la
público o la privada,
la que la que te da el adaptador de
wifi.
Estaba buscando la la pública. No,
no, la es para dentro de la red local
y la que entiendo, pues eso, que habrá
solo un salto
cuando hacemos a Google, por ejemplo,
pues no a Google es que no quiero hacer
Uy,
mira,
mira, lo tienes aquí. P config
sería esta.
Aquí es donde pone esta de aquí, la mía,
por ejemplo, o sea, haces un IP config y
tienes la dirección IPv 4 del tu wifi,
de tu tarjeta R wifi sería 192. O sea,
la mía en este caso es la 60,
la 26.
Lo estaba poniendo como si fuese de
que no no no te rayes.
Estoy acostumbrado a
¿Qué estaba haciendo IF Confi,
sí?
Y decías, ¿por qué no va
confi?
Ay, no, Tracer. Yo me rayo también, ¿no?
A ver, tracer,
que esto en en Linux era de otra manera.
El tracer era en
conservill,
¿no? El la
la utilidad esta de tráer en en Linux es
de otra manera.
Ahora lo miro. Vale, me has dicho la 20
21,
eh, creo que era 26. 26
punto 1.26
est la 26.
Vale, ya está. Uno
estamos dentro de la misma red.
Por otro lado es evidente,
pero bueno, o sea, que no está de más.
Vale, si quieres hacer tú una al mío,
pues lo mismo también.
La 60.
y te aparecerá lo mismo, imagino.
Está bien,
¿no? lo mismo, ¿no? Vale, que es cambia
mucho en el momento hacemos tracer y
decimos, pues eh
vamos a hacerle ahora al servidor de, o
sea, el dominio tame.com, por ejemplo.
Bueno, realmente es
instituto nocomena.
Este también pu
Instituto también
comom, o sea, estando estando en la
misma
en la misma red como si dijéramos, pero
realmente claro, esa sería ahí sí que
está buscando ya el dominio que tal.
Vale, es una diferenciación entre redes
públicas y privadas. Vale, esto es pues
eso, ahí se iría a la
no sería una red local.
Vale,
he cerrado esto. A ver. Vale, entonces,
vale. Utilidades de FTP y TFTP. La
utilidad de FTP sirve para intercambiar
ficheros entre dos nodos de la red,
utilizando el protocolo FTP.
FTP FTP también su parte de cliente y su
parte de servidor. Cuando se ejecuta el
cliente FTP aparece el identificador de
utilidad FTP y el y el simbolito este
sobre la que se ejecutan los comandos
FTP. Listar, ahora lo veremos. traer,
bajar o dejar o dejar subir ficheros,
etcétera. Previamente a la utilización
del FTP, para realizar transferencias es
necesario preparar una conexión segura a
través del protocolo TCP. Esto se
realiza con el comando open seguido
dirección IP o el DNS o el nombre DNS
del host remoto.
El comando TFTP es similar al FTP, más
fácil de configurar pero con menos
prestaciones.
La utilización de un servidor FTP tener
acceso al servidor a través de un nombre
de usuario. Es importantísimo esto. con
una serie de de,
o sea, realmente tenemos con una serie
de permisos otorgados,
¿vale? entraremos con usuario y
contraseña en el caso de que de que el
FTP de que la FTP esté,
o sea, no se nos haya asignado un
usuario o en una FTP pública, que no es
muy recomendable, la verdad,
nunca nunca pongáis, por ejemplo,
permisos de escritura en una FTP pública
porque os van a subir ahí lo que lo que
quieran,
¿vale? Y luego al final los responsables
el vosotros,
¿vale? La utilización de un un nombre de
usuario, una contraseña que nos asignará
la administrador del sistema remoto.
Muchos servidores e internet tienen
información pública a la que se accede
sin necesidad de tener cuenta en el
equipo,
permitiendo conexiones de usuarios
anónimos.
Ejemplo, un ejemplo de ellos, filecilla,
que yo lo puedo instalar aquí.
Pero sí que os sí que lo vamos a mirar
en porque con vosotros no estuve no
estuve mirando, ¿no? Filecilla, no hemos
no hemos mirado nada de esto de FTPs.
Vale, utilidades. Y ya por último nos
queda nos quedaría esta serían
utilidades Telnet y y SSH.
¿Qué dice aquí?
Porque le gusta Redex. Hm.
Claro,
claro. Segundo.
Pues estudia, estudia, estudia. Dale
caña, ¿eh? Dale caña. Muy bien. Me
alegro mucho.
Venga.
Bueno, utilidades del net y SSH sirve
para realizar con
sirve para realizar con remotas
interactivas en forma de terminal
virtual a través del protocolo de alto
nivel Telnet. el comando acompañado en
la dirección IP del nodo remoto o de su
dirección de NS.
Vale, los servidores Windows. Esto lo lo
habéis tocado un segundo, ¿no? Eletidor
Windows.
¿El qué? ¿El qué?
El
las DNS, ¿sí? No, DNS, sí, por supuesto.
Pero
me refiero utilidad el net.
[Música]
SSH sí, pelotel net como tal, ¿no?
Vale, los servidores Windows implementan
un servidor del net que es que sirve
sesiones en forma de ventanas emuladoras
dos para los clientes delnet que se
conectan a ellos desde su red, lo que es
muy interesante para ejecutar scrip de
máquinas remotadas.
En el mundo Linux, la utilidad
equivalente más moderna es SSH.
Esta es una de las utilidades más
versátiles que tiene su parte de cliente
y de servidor. Puede ejecutar
aplicaciones remotas, copiar ficheros,
crear sesiones remotas gráficas, crear
tuneles de comunicación, etcétera.
Funcionalidades SSH. puede sustituir las
conexiones rematadas de Telnet, pero la
gran ventaja de SSH es la cifra es que
cifra las conexiones, por lo que es
mucho más seguro que tenden.
Vale, pues esto sería todo lo todo lo
que sería el material de de esta primera
evaluación,
¿vale? Y ahora pues vamos a a dedicar a
poner en práctica todas estas cosillas
porque si hemos estado mirando que es
FTP
HTTP lo hemos llegado a
A ver si Bueno, se toca así por encima
también.
Vale, pues vamos a
voy a ponerle una marca que como que ha
acabado este
es tu profe de primero,
¿no? De segundo.
De segundo,
sí. Bueno, también de primero.
Vale, hoy es hoy es 20.
Vale. Eh, vamos a, vale, abrir
paquet traser
y poner un
A ver, os digo, espera, os lo pongo
aquí.
Y ahora hacemos el ejercicio y vais vais
construyendo la red esta.
Vamos a cogerte.
Espera
que voy a preparar un ejercicio.
Que vamos a ver el funcionamiento
pues de de estos dos protocolos, ¿no?,
que sería la HTTP, por ejemplo, y FTP,
¿vale?
BHCP lo os suena. Lo estuvimos mirando
también. Lo digo por repasar todo este
tipo de cosas. Bueno, entiendo que a
vosotros de segundo sí que sí que os
suena, pero vosotros de primero, los que
no estáis repitiendo, ¿os suena el que
tocamos de HCP? O sea, la asignación de
de IPS, básicamente de forma automática.
Automática me parece que no.
No, pues vamos a vamos a empezar por
ahí.
Me me parece que son estático.
Vale, pues vamos a empezar por esto,
¿vale? Y así vemos las dos las dos
maneras y luego ya pasamos a pasamos a
otras cosas.
Vale, venga. Pues en primer lugar sería
vamos a un servidor, o sea, lo
podíamos hacer realmente podíamos
implementarlo en un router, pero nos
tendríamos que ir a a implementarlo con
código,
¿vale? Y bueno, se puede hacer también,
pero vamos a hacerlo de forma gráfica y
ya.
y ya lo haremos con mediante mediante
código en el router
creando la creando la red y todo eso.
¿Vale? Entonces nos venimos aquí y
creamos un servidor,
¿vale? Nos le vamos a poner un
switch,
¿vale? y hm y a este switch, o sea, y
este y a estos dos PCs que vamos a poner
aquí, le vamos a decir
que nos los asigne las direcciones de de
forma de forma automática mediante de
HCP,
¿vale? Si nosotros cogemos,
a ver, vamos a conectar todo.
Vale, teníamos la forma automática de
conectar y la forma manual en la que
vamos eligiendo,
¿vale? O sea, una vez sabemos eso, pues
ya podemos ir haciendo de forma de forma
automática,
¿vale? Y aquí nos vendríamos, ¿vale? Al
server,
¿vale? Nos venimos aquí a este primer,
bueno, realmente vamos a hacerlo de dos
maneras. Vamos a hacerlo así y vamos a
hacerlo configurando un router también
mediante mediante código.
¿Vale? Entonces,
eh,
nos venimos aquí a esto, ¿vale? Y aquí
en la configuración IP de este primer
ordenador
le decimos de HP, DHCP,
¿vale? Y entonces, ¿recuerdas, eh,
bueno, los
recordáis que estuvimos hablando de las
direcciones IP,
las que nos asignaba el
las que las que se nos asignaban de
forma automática en el momento que no se
encontraba una red y tenías puesto en
modo de HCP el
Sí,
vale. Pues sería esto, sería una pipa de
estas,
¿vale? nos la ha asignado porque
realmente no hay nada que esté
sirviendo. O sea, esto está diciendo,
"Dame, dame dame dirección, dame una
dirección." Pero nadie le está le está
ofreciendo una dirección. Y para que
alguien le ofrezca una dirección
necesitamos que haya alguien,
es una redundancia, pero pero realmente
necesitamos alguien que esté diciendo,
pues toma esta dirección, esta para ti y
esta para ti. ¿Vale? Entonces es lo que
vamos a hacer ahora.
Vale, nos venimos aquí al server
y aquí en
aquí en services service nos venimos al
al módulo de de DHCP y lo que vamos a
crear es un es un ámbito realmente
eh es como lo llamaríamos luego en la
luego Windows Server y todos estos.
Vale,
vamos a Bueno, en primer lugar, vale,
que me estoy rayando. Vale, nos venimos,
espera, nos venimos aquí y configuramos
configuramos el server con su dirección
IP propia, ¿vale? Esta podría ser
192.168 168
punto
pun 20 pun 10, por ejemplo,
¿vale? Que es una red de clase C,
¿vale? Y como puerta de enlace le
podemos poner la misma
192.168
20.10.
Vale. Y este y este servidor lo
tendríamos en modo eh en modo estático,
¿vale? Esta sería la dirección del del
server, ¿vale? Entonces, ahora una vez
hecho esto, nos venimos
nos venimos a donde
aquí, ¿vale? DHCP le decimos cuál es la
la puerta de enlace predeterminada.
Pues la dirección del sería la dirección
de este
de este de este equipo, de este
servidor, ¿vale? Que sería 192 168.
20.10.
el DNS, el servidor DNS realmente no lo
tenemos configurado ni lo a lo mejor en
este adaptor de red no lo queremos tener
configurado para para
ningún servidor de NS,
¿vale? Podríamos poner 888,
que sería el de Google,
¿vale? Y aquí le diríamos
cuántas, a ver, es una red de clase C,
¿vale? Lo que lo que
lo que vamos a montar. ¿Hasta cuántas
direcciones podemos tener una red de
clase C?
O sea, ¿cuántas direcciones nos puede
nos puede dar? Empezamos con 192
pun 168
punto 20. La 10 la tenemos asignada.
Pues por ejemplo, a ver, lo ideal es que
hubiéramos puesto la uno,
la dos, no, la uno, no. La Sí. Bueno,
eh,
podemos poner la 15, ¿vale? O o la o la
50. y de la 50.
Aquí pondríamos 255 porque es de clase
C. 255
255 y este sería cero. ¿Vale? ¿Cuánto
sería el número de de conexiones máximas
que si
las direcciones que va a enviar? O sea,
a ver, dicho de otra manera, tenemos un
taco de tarjetas y gente para dársela,
¿hasta cuántas? ¿Hasta cuántas podemos
repartir?
Hasta 255 puede ser.
Sí, pero la última date cuenta que que
estaría esa estaría ocupada, sería hasta
la 254,
¿vale? Entonces realmente sería desde la
50 incluida hasta la 254, que son,
si no me equivoco, son 204, ¿no?
Sí. Vale, entonces pondríamos 204.
2011, no, 204.
Si queréis vamos a acotarlo más y vamos
a,
bueno, sí, nos lo dejamos así, no vamos
a hacer tampoco aquí, ¿vale? Entonces,
le decimos,
le ponemos un nombre, pues este sería el
20, por ejemplo, ¿no? Porque porque la
tenemos en la tenemos en 20.
y le decimos que que la añada. Y esta
esta es la carga que no la queremos.
Bueno, esa nada,
no se la carga. Ah, vale, la tenemos en
el momento la ponemos aquí, ¿no? Bueno,
esa la tenemos apagada y esta la
encendemos, ¿vale? Es importante que
encendamos esto.
¿En qué en qué interfaz? ¿En qué tarjeta
de red? En esta. O sea, imaginad que
tuviéramos varias, que en este caso creo
que solo tiene una, pero imaginad que
tuviéramos que tuviéramos alguna otra,
pues ahí sí que tendríamos que poner que
el servicio lo implementamos, pero en
esa tarjeta de red en concreto.
¿Vale? A ver, mi teoría es que al primer
ordenador que asigne, que va a ser este,
le va a poner la 50. Luego aplicaremos a
este la que obtenga la el
direccionamiento IP
y le pondrá la 251, o sea, perdón, la 51
y por último haremos este y le pondrá la
52.
¿Vale? Entonces le decimos que que
guarde.
Vale, es que yo me quería cargar a esta.
A ver,
esta está encendida. Y esto, esto sé que
nos puede dar problema.
Vale, esta está encendida. Esta está
apagada ahora. No creo que está apagada.
Vale, a ver, me cargo. Vale, lo voy a
hacer de nuevo, ¿eh? Es que si no, Vale,
estamos en este. Le voy a poner 20.
Si le pongo 20 y le digo guardar,
modificar o editar,
hay que añadirlo. Vale, pero es que lo
que no quiero es que me haga que me haga
jaleos.
Bueno,
no me deja guardarlo. Vale, pues espera.
No, no escribáis nada.
Lo que le voy a decir es que lo guarde.
A ver, en el momento yo cambio esto
y le digo guardar. Nada, me dice lo
mismo.
Le ponemos este 20.
Vale, voy a hacer, voy a poner los
mismos datos de nuevo.
Vale, le decimos 192
pun 168.20.10.
Esto lo tenemos en 50,
esta está en cero y esta habíamos dicho
204, ¿no?
Vale, le decimos que
eh ¿Por qué me lo cambiado?
Vale, si yo pongo así, no es que me lo
cambie. A ver si la tengo apagada.
No quiero escribirlo. A ver.
Vale, ahora sí. Vale. Aquí le ponemos
pun 255.255
pun0.
Vale, le decimos que que lo guarde
y aquí le ponemos 204,
¿vale? Y que lo guarde.
Esta la tenemos encendida
y esta estaría apagada.
Bueno,
¿ven?
Buena. Esto es que,
o sea, a ver si es que tengo
seleccionada esta. Vale, me la la tiré
arriba. Entiendo que por defecto la de
arriba
es que era un poco puñetero, pero bueno,
vamos a ver si
Vale, entonces.
Vale, aquí vemos que le ha puesto la la
21, ¿no? Lo que queremos es
¿Por qué le ha puesto la 20? Porque
igual le he puesto aquí la
Ah, vale, porque está en cero. Vale,
entonces se habíamos dicho 50.
Vale, hacemos guardar.
A ver si lo coges.
Y ahora sí que debería
ahora cuando
yo no sé si en la consola dejar
la tienes que poner eh estática y luego
volverla a poner.
Sí, sí, sí. Me imagino que sí, pero
podemos hacerlo también mediante
mediante la consola si me deja.
diciéndole IP config y diciéndole que lo
renueve, que renueve la configuración
IP. A ver si me deja. Espera,
que eso es lo fácil,
¿vale? Pero vamos a intentar hacerlo con
consola. Si nos deja. A ver, IP config
barra
eh
bueno, primero si nos admite el IP
config, que yo creo que sí. Vale, está
en 21. Ahora decimos IP config
barra ayuda ir al renu.
A ver,
Reno, ¿vale? IP config.
Tenemos IP configo.
Y en teoría
nos debería
nos debería cambiar
el relance,
¿vale? y fi rend.
Vale, pues lo hacemos por las pruebas,
que sería básicamente eso,
venirnos aquí, decirle estática y el
truco mendruco es eso.
Bueno,
está en 50, está guardado, o sea, nos
debería poner la 50, ¿vale? En vez de la
en vez de esta
y sí que lo hemos puesto todo bien.
Eh, me parece que se interfiere con el
server pool, el que no tienes
configurado porque a mí me estaba
pasando lo mismo. Entonces, al tener ese
server pool que empieza en cero,
empiezan en uno cada terminal.
¿A cuál te refieres?
Eh, el de abajo del todo que pone
Silverpool y abajo.
Yo yo creo que Ah, vale, con este. Es
verdad. Sí, sí, sí, sí, sí. Vale, vale,
vale.
Mira, tienes toda la razón. Sí,
vale. Pero es que este
yo en vez de eso, en vez de hacer un
server pull nuevo, eh he cambiado el que
ya está hecho y ya está.
Es que no me porque si no como que
Pero no has visto que no me dejaba
cambiar los valores. Por eso he creado
uno nuevo, porque no
sí que me deja, no sé por qué. No, yo me
he puesto a hacerlo y por eso por eso ha
sido, o sea, pero en teoría y lo has
puesto así 50 y tal
mismo.
Claro, claro.
Es que a ver, voy a quitar esto.
Vale,
que sí.
un
aquí había algo en
es que es persistente, ¿eh? Madre mía.
Sí, pero sí es eso. Es que está igual es
el el tipo de servidor. A ver.
A ver, voy a hacerlo de nuevo porque
esto no puede ser. Vamos a
quita el server pool 20. Intenta volver
a configurar.
Sí, voy a crear otro.
¿Tú a cuál has cogido? ¿Este o este?
Este de aquí, ¿no?
El tercero. Sí, ese es lo mismo.
Vale, entonces nos venimos aquí,
conectamos.
Apagamos.
Vale. Y aquí en configuración, claro,
está apagando. Sí, sí, sí. Sí,
digo yo, voy a hacerle el
truquillo, ¿no?
Vale, entonces aquí en el server pool
este,
¿vale? Eh,
le decim, bueno, en en off, a ver, ¿tú
has empezado por aquí o has empezado por
por algún otro? Yo estaba haciendo lo
mismo de poner server Pool 20 y me
pasaba eso. Entonces, eh he quitado el
server Pool 20, he seleccionado el que
ya está hecho y he cambiado los valores
y guard cambiado los valores y ya está.
Claro, es que ya te digo, a mí no me
dejaba guardarlo. Voy a ver si ahora al
poner esto 192 168.2.10.
Le digo guardar. Vale, ahora sí,
ahora sí,
ahora sí. Vale, ahora sí que va a
funcionar. 255
255.255
5 C, perdón.
Eh, de ese server no teníamos nada
puesto.
Ay, no, es verdad que me he rayado.
Me he rayado. Sí, sí.
Vale,
vale. 192
punto 168
punto 20
y punto 10.
No, 50. No, 50.
Vale. Y aquí sí que iría al 25,
¿no? Donde antes.
Vale. Y aquí 204.
Vale. En denés estaba 0.0.0
pun, ¿no? O no había nada.
0.0.0 puntos.
Vale, ahora sí. Vale, no me dejaba, por
eso no me dejaba guardarlo antes
porque en el momento que lo he
modificado ya no me dejaba.
Vale, aquí le ponemos de máximas 204,
que es lo que
Uy, y se va al uno. 200.
Es por la máscara de Red,
¿no?
Sí, totalmente. Muy bien, Jorge.
Sí que es verdad. Digo, 204. Vale, es
que yo no sé por qué he puesto el 255
ese al final.
Bueno, ahora sí que debería de
funcionar. Ya le ponemos en en on.
Guardamos.
Vale, y como lo hemos cambiado, ahora sí
que habría que
añadir la dirección
estática del propio servidor, que no es
más que 192 168
20.10
y nos calcula la la máscara de red. Y
ahora sí que en teoría
al ponerle un
lo pasamos a estática
y cambiamos a Ahora sí que nos pone ya
la 50.
Vale,
vale. Aquí por lo mismo nos venimos aquí
p config de HCP 51 será lo que nos
pondrá.
Y aquí
lo mismo,
¿vale? HP
52 hay dos.
Vale, cambia la película en el momento
que nosotros no tenemos un server,
¿vale? Y lo que tenemos es un un router,
por ejemplo.
Vale, vamos a ver este, por ejemplo,
y este nos lo cargamos,
¿vale? Y ahora lo que queremos es que
nos asciende la IP.
de forma
automática
el propio router y decimos, "Vale, pues
muy fácil, me voy aquí y ostras, pues no
tiene
no tiene configuración, ¿vale? Para de
de HCP, ¿vale? Pues no pasa nada porque
aquí sí que nos venimos ya a la a la
consola.
Vale, le damos a intro y esto era
tenemos que poner un enable.
Hola, dime.
Perdón,
[Música]
dime.
Eh, no he podido leer los emails en
detalle porque son muchísimos y estoy en
clase, pero me ha parecido ver esto y yo
a esta hora tengo clase con los niños.
Tenía que ser de cinco a seis.
Sí.
O que los vigieráis vosotros. Espera
si no se puede modificar.
No, si yo es que a ver, me lo encuentro
así, digo, pues este
como no sé si lo has hecho tú o tal como
eso, te lo digo a ti.
Mira,
espera que esto sí es que la verdad es
que son correos largos, ¿eh? El de el de
Dan sí que ponía de cinco a se, o sea,
sí, de cinco a seis, pero
mira, sería el martes, ese sería el
jueves, ¿no?
Sí, jueves 13
de cinco de seis de seis a siete.
De seis a siete. Yo no puedo.
No puedes.
Si los tenéis que dejar.
V. Es que yo lo he puesto, ¿no? Mira, lo
he puesto. Pues van a ser unos cuantos,
eh, ese porque son ocho de ocho de SMR2.
Y a ver,
¿ves? Es que yo he visto esto y digo,
pues lo pongo lo mismo, porque yo creía
que sí que lo habéis hablado vosotros.
Es que no me lo he leído todo ni
siquiera porque estoy viendo que algunos
sí que tienen tres trimestres, otros dos
que es un jaleo y digo, "Buah, esto yo
me lo tengo que estudiar porque es que
no no entiendo lo que decí." Yo yo he
calculado que son en bueno, estos son
los que él ha calculado, que es el
número máximo de alumnos que pueden
presentarse.
Pero de Pero, ¿de dónde sale tanto
alumno? Si tenemos cuatro gatos. ¿Dónde
sale?
En tu inglés, por ejemplo, de
En inglés de segundo son mucho.
Claro, claro. Es que Vale, aquí me he
rayado yo. Es que aquí me
tenéis más vosotros, pero yo tengo seis,
siete en segundo.
Pero sí que se puede hacer el examen de
inglés. Sí que se sí que lo podéis hacer
porque nosotros vamos a utilizar el
mismo aula. Eso
sí que lo he leído abajo en la 11 para
que que es que nosotras tenemos
disponibilidad aquí
pues tenés disponibilidad esas aulas.
Pues oye, pues ahí se puede hacer,
pero que mi problema es el horario, ¿no?
El horario es el que, o sea, eso lo
podemos cambiar que eso no hay problema.
Vale, si se puede cambiar
no tienes que trastocarlo todo.
Lo único que tienes que tener en cuenta
si lo cambias es Yo he puesto esta
propuesta, ¿vale?
Porque aquí, por ejemplo,
fíjate que el que el martes
no hay después de de inglés, o sea,
mira,
no hay
no hay exámenes. Entonces, yo he
aprovechado para que no se lle las aulas
tanto,
he aprovechado y he puesto
redes locales y sistemas operativos
moduesto para los de para los de primero
para que vengan y ya aprovechen el viaje
y hagan los tres exámenes. Es
estupendo. Claro, si yo simplemente es
por la hora. A mí me da igual que sea un
día o los días me da igual. Yo de hecho
tengo que estar aquí. Claro, porque tú
tienes a gente de otro de otros. Claro,
claro, claro. No, no, que tienes razón.
¿Y tú cuándo podrías entonces?
Mismo día, pero en lugar de seis a 7,
cinco a se
de cinco a seis.
Cualquier día de cinco a seis.
Cualquier día de cinco a se lo tienes
bien. Cinco a se
ese sí.
Vale, pues ahora lo hablo yo con José
Vicente también.
Y este
martes 11. Es que tengo clase ahora y no
quiero tampoco entrar muy tarde.
Entonces, el martes 11 serían los de
primero, ¿no?
Es que este no lo he visto, solo me he
fijado en este. Este, este no lo he
visto yo. Vale, 11 y 13, sí, de
noviembre. 11 y 13 de noviembre, ¿no?
El 11 y luego el 13. Pues claro, si eso
te va mal, pues la verdad es que
no que vaya mal, es que no puedo. O sea,
si Claro, otra cosa es que digáis, "No
quiero cambiar nada ya, entonces
vigiláis vosotros." Mira, podemos hacer
una cosa. Claro, lo que pasa que hace
falta que vengan con ordenador para
examen. No,
no, de hecho
escrito.
De hecho, hay que recordarles, les tengo
que decir que llega
los lunes. El de no puede.
Es que mi hora es esa la que tengo. No
tengo. Además, el lunes es peor porque
es hacemos las horas a la media de 5:30,
pero es que no no tengo otras horas.
Tiene que ser ahí de 5 a
tiene que ser de 5 a se
tiene que ser cuando tenemos clase de
lunes 5 a 6. Martes, jueves, lunes, eh,
o sea, martes, vale, pues lo cambiamos
eso. Si es que a nosotros nos da igual,
si este examen es de una hora se cambia
uno por otro. Vale,
vale, vale. Que no te estaba entendiendo
eso.
Mi duda era si no podíais cambiar ya
algún examen, pero si quería cambiar.
Claro. Yo, hombre, a ver, José Vicente
sí que ha enviado
realmente a los alumnos sí que les ha
enviado un correo, pero yo no sé si
ahora cuando termine este grupo de
Vale, si quieres me, si quieres me
llamas y paso yo también y hablamos.
igual te como debes si puede ser igual
también te interrumpe otra vez,
¿no? Bueno, íbamos a hacer a una ir
cacharreando aquí un poquito con esto.
Pero lo dejamos ya no tenemos que
estarlo otra vez.
Por eso lo digo porque ya que hemos
tomado el tema,
eh, escuchadme cacharrear aquí un poco
más que es,
¿vale? con el buscar buscar comandos
para activar el DHCP en un router.
Vale, y luego lo miramos.
Ahora voy a voy a hablar una cosa de los
exámenes.
mal.
A ver, vale, ya estoy por aquí.
Vale, entonces nos venimos Vamos.
Vale, tenemos que poner aquí. Ahora ya
nadie les está
les está asignando esa dirección IP,
¿vale? Y posiblemente ahora
pues nada, esto si nos venimos aquí, lo
ponemos en estática
y volvemos a poner de CCP, pues ahora sí
que nos devuelve la pipa este,
¿vale?
Vale, entonces ahora
para crear este
este
DHCP,
¿vale? Nos venimos al al router y en su
configuración,
¿vale? Volvemos, le damos intro otra
vez, ¿vale?
Activamos con mediante enable
la configuración,
¿vale? Ya se nos pone en modo
en modo activo. ¿Vale? Entonces, ahora
lo que vamos a crear,
¿vale? A ver, espera que me centre con
los comanditos.
Vale,
vale. Ahora le ponemos vamos a
configurar la
Ethernet,
¿vale? Que sería en este caso está
conectada. A ver, solo tiene tiene uno o
tiene dos.
Este, ¿cuál? A ver, espera. Es que este
este nos lo cargamos. Este no sería.
A ver, el crotter. Vamos a
el PT router, ¿no?
El PT router está bien. Sí, el dos el
281 también tampoco va mal. Si está,
creo que está por el final
este,
¿vale? Que es este sí que tendría
tendrían los dos adaptadores. El PT
router, pues también lo que pasa que el
PT router sí que tiene sí que tiene para
hacerlo mediante mediante opción
gráfica, ¿no?
Me suena. No tengo ni idea.
A ver,
pero es como, o sea, es el que salen
todas las
actividades.
Bueno, pero eso, a ver, podemos
este. A ver, PT router tiene.
Y si nos venimos aquí,
vale,
podemos el PT router y podemos
este también. Cualquiera de los
dos nos serviría, ¿vale? ¿Por qué? Pues
porque tienen el el puerto fast eternet
en la tarjeta R esta, ¿vale? En la
interfaz,
¿vale? Cualquiera de los dos nos vendría
bien. Eh, vamos a conectar al
al PT router.
Venga, nos venimos aquí, aquí y vamos a
la 00. Lo he conectado bien a la 00.
Espera,
soltado ahí a lo tonto.
Vale, venimos aquí
y ahí. Vale,
vale. Creo que este Bueno, nada, a ver,
vamos a ponerlo así. Vale, le decimos
intro
en
vale y ahora vamos a configurar.
Lo tenemos con enorción,
¿vale? Entonces nos vamos a
configure terminal,
escribimos configure
terminal
puerto con figura.
Es que he puesto configur configure.
Vale, vale, ya estamos en modo
configuración. Sí.
Vale, ahora una vez entramos en modo
configuración, lo que vamos a vamos a
configurar es el en la tarjeta de red, o
sea, lo que le vamos a es añadir una
dirección una dirección IP, o sea,
necesitamos que que tenga una dirección
una dirección ese router,
¿vale? para que los para que los
dispositivos y la puerta de enlace,
¿vale?, lo dirija los dispositivos hacia
hacia este router. Entonces, esto lo
hacemos mediante
eh Vale, tenemos la almohadilla esta.
Ahora pone, a ver si lo escribo bien.
Interface
fast
etern
barra porque es como se llama la la
tarjeta esta, ¿vale? Si no os habéis
fijado, luego lo luego lo vemos.
Vale, sería alfase 00 y así sin espacio
y sin nada. Creo que lo he escrito bien.
A ver. Vale, vale. Entramos dentro de, o
sea, ahora lo que tenemos es que añadir
la dirección IP que queremos, que sería
IP address,
en este caso 192.16.
Vamos a vamos a poner otras para que no
sean las mismas de de antes,
¿vale? Entonces vamos a poner 92 168
pun 40.0
por ejemplo. Lo digo por no hacer
siempre las mismas. Y luego le ponemos
la máscara de R, que sería 255
punto 255 pun 255 punto y ahora no voy a
otro 255. Pongo cero que no lo pase como
antes.
Vale, me dice que es mal.
Algo he puesto mal. ¿Qué he puesto mal?
1926 840
punto cer
es por el punto cería punto uno. O sea,
con el, o sea, con 40.1
Correcto, correcto, correcto. Sí, sí,
sí, sí. Es el punto cero. Tienes toda la
razón. Es el punto uno.
Vale, ahora sí. Muy bien. Vale. Y ahora
le decimos no shutdown.
Faltando
Vale, le hacemos intro.
Vale, y ya tendríamos el router.
Vale, ya tenemos el router con ese IP.
V. Gracias Jorge que
a veces con tanto con tanto jaleo.
Vale, por un lado le hemos puesto
la la dirección la dirección de la red
que sería el 40 y por otro lado hemos
hemos configurado la dirección del
router.
¿Y por qué con cero no funciona y y con
un
no? Porque cero sería cero. Lo vamos a
utilizar ahora para la red de para la
red de DHCP. Ahí sí que sí que sería el,
o sea, sería la red el primer
la primera dirección de la red, que
sería el uno, estaría destinado al al
dispositivo, ¿no?, que es que es el que
nos lanza toda la
todas las IPS. Y el otro está está,
o sea, el otro no serviría para
determinar la la red.
Vale. Eh, siguiente paso sería
configurar el el de HCP.
Vale, salimos de esta configuración. A
ver, eh,
protocolo
tan.
Vale, ahora salimos de Bueno, si queréis
vamos a lo comprobamos esto, ¿vale?
Tenemos este es este de aquí, ¿vale? Y
efectivamente el fase eternos en 40,
¿vale?
Eh,
siguiente paso.
Bueno, los tenemos en este lo teníamos
en Apipa,
¿vale? Y estos me imagino que seguirán.
Vale, pero si les decimos,
espera,
hacemos estática, hacemos el truco
almendruco, pues vuelven otra vez al a
la viva porque nadie les está les está
sugiriendo nada.
Estática
y HP.
Vale, ahí lo tenemos. Venga, nos venimos
aquí. Vale, salimos de esta
configuración del,
bueno, de la configuración que tenemos,
le decimos exit,
¿vale? Y ahora nos vamos a la
configuración
normal,
¿vale? Y le decimos IP, vamos a
configurar el DHCP.
Pull y le vamos a poner IP. Está en que
estábamos en en 40, ¿no? Pues lo ponemos
IP40
para llamarla de de alguna manera.
Creo que hemos escrito bien todo. Sí.
Vale,
vale. Siguiente paso de
work.
192.168
pun 40.0.
Aquí sí que vendría el cero, ¿vale?
Porque ya es la
ya se ya estamos estamos diciendo
esta red donde desde dónde empieza
255.0.
Vale. Y ahora lo que le vamos a decir es
la IP del router también, que sería
default
default router. Si le damos a tabulador
nos saca las
nos saca el siguiente comando, sería
192.168.40.1.
Vale.
Y ahora le decimos exit.
y ya lo tendríamos configurado.
Vale, para verlo
lo tenía por aquí en una chuletilla
para ver la configuración.
Una vez lo tenemos hecho. Espera un
segundo.
Ahora te lo digo, ¿eh?
Vale, a todo esto, pues nada, ahora sí
nos venimos aquí. Ahora sí que nos
debería de veis ya le asignado la tres a
este
la dos a este y la y la cuatro a este
porque la uno la tiene la tiene el
router realmente.
Vale, ¿cómo podemos ver la configuración
de esta red? ¿Cómo era? Espera.
Vale. Este comando es que está está
bien.
Digo,
A ver.
Lo digo, espera.
sencillo como
lo tenemos en
en
decimos
a ver
o posiblemente tengamos que salir de la
configuración
sitro.
Estamos en el
en el router, eh, no tengo, vale, no, sí
estamos en el en el enable, ¿vale? Y le
decimos show room y ya está. O sea, no
tiene más, pero claro, si es que al
final, ¿vale? Entonces ahí nos dice la
configuración del router.
Vale, pues eso sería
hasta hoy.
El próximo día pues veremos TF
HTTP, FTPs.
Vale,
vale, vale. Pues vamos a pasar ahora
el siguiente. Esto era lo de antes, ¿no?
Este también.